it's an experience we long for in these
days of the coronavirus breaking bread
in a comfortable space with a room full
of others no social distancing required
on this special edition of the dish
we'll take you back to one such evening
held at New York's Gramercy Tavern just
before the crisis began the event a
celebration for Jubilee a truly
remarkable recipe book and it's James
Beard award-winning author on this
February evening at the auspicious
Gramercy Tavern Tony Tipton Martyn
[Music]
offers guests a taste of her Jubilee
this is the hardest station in the
kitchen executive chef Michael Anthony's
special invitation is called a tavern
takeover and is usually reserved only
for celebrated restaurant alum
but Tipton Martin's dishes are
considered worthy after all they were
centuries in the making a little garnish
from peanuts to the barbecued shrimp the
cookbook is companion tour 2016 Award
winner the Jemima code the provocatively
titled source detailing a virtual who's
who of black chefs and there are 200
year impact on the American palate so
the mission of the Jemima code was the
mission was to debunk the mythology that
says african-american women in
particular but men too were illiterate
cooks who cooked by some kind of a
mysterious mystique right this idea of
soul cooking what they were were trained
apprentices whether that job was in the
plantation kitchen or in restaurants
these were people who had on-the-job
experience professionals in places that
might surprise you
the Massachusetts governor's mansion
where Butler Robert Roberts penned a
household management book in 1827 with
recipes or on TV where in 1940 New
Orleans restaurateur Lena Rashard beat
the likes of Julia Child to the airwaves
and in New York's famed gauge and toner
where Edna Lewis made regional Southern
cuisine exceptional in New York's fine
dining circles we are just excited to
have you here today
the former Los Angeles Times food writer
is eager to share this knowledge and
thanks allies like chef Anthony for
amplifying not only her voice but other
chefs of color and women and I'm trying
to return us to the place where we're
willing to look at that plate and take
apart who we are who's represented there
he's trying to expand that practice in
his own kitchen one reason he introduced
tipton Martin to his team sous chef
Arita ATAR wasn't alone in her
appreciation we could all learn from
each other
I'm just well I just want everyone else
to be better we all want it what did you
learn from Jubilee it not only opened my
eyes to many new sources of food and
recipes that have come through years and
years of her scholarly work but she's
opened the door to something that is
brand new okay let's dig in for the soup
Oh
oh my gosh and the shrimp I can tell you
that I used to despise my Jubilees 320
pages provide an assortment of a hundred
and twenty brilliantly photographed
entrees sides and sweets I wanted to
make sure that the dishes reflected some
aspect of West African tradition whether
that was through the botany and the
ingredients like okra and greens I
wanted to make sure that the recipes
conveyed african-american migration that
we were able to substantiate food
traditions don't exist only in the south
fan favorites are all over the place
Louisiana red beans and rice yes the
book goes on to includes the things that
we would expect to find there like fried
chicken but there are adaptations and
versions of fried chicken
there's homestyle fried chicken there's
pressure cooker Fried Chicken the
practice that we now know was
commercialized as KFC most importantly
totally gives credit to those who
created these dishes so what I did was
look through the recipe collections over
the years to see which recipes recurred
over and over again until I got to
modern cookbooks like this one for crab
chowder found in the 2015 cookbook of
cordon bleu trained chef and rapper
Kelis Martin traces it back to the
she-crab soup of William Dee's Abel
Butler to the first lady of South
Carolina in the 1930s so this is a
collaboration of many different recipes
right word a newfound Bible for a people
whose conch
abuse ins to the art and science of
culinary know-how has often been
overlooked I'm on this cake yes just not
by the pair seated at her side what is
it
this is Melinda Russell's lemon tea cake
hmm there was a time when citrus was a
very expensive commodity and so the idea
that an african-american would be able
to use lemon to this degree is one of
those ways that I'm illustrating the
sumptuousness of our cooking as opposed
to survivals what are you wouldn't a lot
of aha moments in there it was good
tasting food but really a knowledgeable
jam-packed book full of things that make
you go hmm tons of information Rochelle
I'd great books by you today Russia now
Jubilee really good stuff there it is
all right